[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
July 11th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
for many student loan borrowers the
resumption of payments means having to
work those payments back into their
budgets but for years many of them had
redirected that money to other areas of
their finances we'll talk with wsj
reporter Joe pinsker about the big
picture in a moment but first 30 year
old Texas resident and student loan
borrower Trey Watson joins us so Trey
before the payments pause in 2020 what
did your student loans look like and how
much in monthly payments were you making
yeah before the pause I was making about
400 a month payments it was minimum 285
I believe but I paid the extra to get
paid off faster I had 20 500 left when
they paused them how'd you feel each
month when you were making those
payments
um it just was kind of dreaded you know
this money could be going towards my
future instead of my past so when the
pause went into effect how did that
affect your finances honestly it was
like a huge burden lifted at the time I
was kind of burnt out with work and not
having that commitment I was able to
actually you know just quit my job
during covid and stay at home I was my
mom's caregiver at the time so I
couldn't be exposed and it was just a
nice relief to not have to worry about
that one extra payment each month so
what'd you do with that money so I
started putting it aside first for an
emergency savings fund and then since I
didn't have a job I kind of wanted to
start becoming self-employed or you know
be able to keep the remote work thing
after covid and so I started investing
in my own little business where I do
marketing on the side of course I do
have a full-time remote job but I do
work with a few organizations here and
there on the side doing digital
marketing for them I was also able to
save up a down payment for a new car it
was my first car that I purchased on my
own my previous one was a gift from my
grandma to get me through college and
such and I had it for 10 years so that
was a nice relief and kind of my first
big adult purchase I got to make after
college now before President Biden
proposed the loan forgiveness plan were
you putting any money away you know just
in case the payments pause were to end
yes I had been saving up a little bit of
like a cushion but not as much because I
was being optimistic about it getting
canceled but I did put a little bit of
emergency buffer aside in case it like
suddenly started out of thin air but as
I see they're probably going to do this
on-ramp things so that gives me a nice
window of time to start saving up some
more right that's the 12-month program
that'll prevent those who miss their
payments from defaulting on their loans
or having their credit adversely
affected what adjustments do you see
you'll have to make in your finances
yeah it kind of feels like a step back
from being a full adult you know I was
able to purchase a new car start a
business and now I'm going to be limited
again with this burdensome payment that
I haven't been making for years do you
see it affecting your purchasing power
or maybe the money you can put toward
the business you have as far as like my
personal spending I definitely you know
won't be able to treat myself as much
you know maybe reduce the amount of
trips I go on also just general spending
as well I actually haven't really
thought about that I guess I've just
been thinking about like I need to make
the payment and not like what the
impacts of that are if I'm being totally
honest because it's been such a roller
coaster you know it's like this week
it's canceled next week it's not now we
have a new plan it's very back and forth
that's Texas resident Trey Watson Trey
thanks very much for being with us thank
you so much Jay I appreciate you all
having me on now let's bring in Wall
Street Journal personal Finance reporter
Joe pinsker so Joe we heard from Trey
that having to pay off loans feels like
he's kind of taking a step back in
adulthood out of his feelings compared
to other borrowers you spoke with what I
heard from other borrowers was both
disappointment and also a general lack
of surprise the disappointment makes a
lot of sense because if the plan had
gone through you know there were about
20 million people who would have been
eligible to have all of their debt wiped
out and for many people this is a huge
monthly burden that really seemed like
there was a good chance it might go away
at the same time people weren't exactly
shocked that the plan didn't go through
some of them were of course genuinely
optimistic when President Biden
announced the plan last summer but
because of the legal challenges and the
current composition of the Supreme Court
they weren't really counting on it to
actually go through student debt
payments have been on pause for about
three years what did borrowers do during
that period Trey who we heard from
earlier is a great example of the this
and I spoke with others who similarly
were able to reach some important
Financial Milestones over the past three
years I've heard from people who were
finally able to start building emergency
savings people who pulled together a
down payment on a house after thinking
that they never would have been able to
get there a monthly payment of hundreds
of dollars can really add up over the
course of three years and for a lot of
people that really made a big difference
some also took the payment pause which
was of course also a pause on the
accumulation of Interest as an
opportunity to pay down their student
debt now you spoke to a couple of
borrowers and many borrowers haven't
ever had to make payments on their loans
how are they now factoring these
payments into their budgets because this
payment pause has gone on from the
spring of 2020 to now we've now seen
several college classes graduate into a
world where they don't have to make
payments yet a trade association called
the student loan servicing Alliance
their estimate was that 7 million people
have either graduated or left school and
haven't had to make a payment you know
some of those first years out of college
can be when people have the most
difficulty financially and many of those
people some of whom I talk to are
grateful to have had a little extra
breathing room over the past couple
years and in the fall the idea of giving
up that Breathing Room in their budgets
is pretty concerning how will the
Supreme Court's decision have a
long-term impact on the lives of young
people in this situation having to make
a debt payment every month we know from
existing research can make a big
difference in people's ability to reach
certain Financial Milestones like buying
a home or saving for retirement and as
I've reported on before this is
especially crucial when people are young
and making important decisions that will
set them on certain life trajectories
whether it's about what career they
pursue or whether they take a risk and
start a business or where they live or
whether they buy a house these are
important years during which people's
trajectories are in some ways set and
whether they hold debt or not at that
age ends up being really consequential
that's Wall Street Journal personal
finance reporter Joe pinsker and that's
your money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for
the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you